Do you know that the acceleration equals (2π)² r/T²,
but on the other hand we have Newton's law telling us that this acceleration is G*mE/r².
This yields the following. Multiply both sides by r² , (2π)²r/T²=G*mE/r².
Let's take r² over here, T² over here, (2π)² over here, so we have,
if r³ is whatever remains on the right hand side, r itself is the ³ √ GmET²/(2π)²
and if you plug in the numbers, that's about 42,000 km,
which is the same as the length of the equator of the earth.
So this spacecraft, the distance between the spacecraft and the center of the earth
has to be almost the same as the length of the equator of the circumference of the earth.
Remember that the distance between that spacecraft and the center of the earth
is not the height of that spacecraft.
To get the height, you would have to subtract the radius of the earth.